luke and jake here with the outdoor boys
youtube channel and we want to show you
guys something awesome check
this
out we're spending three days fishing
camping and exploring the cipher swamps
of north carolina you ready jake
[Music]
do
[Music]
gonna take it slow and easy in here
really easy to jack up a prop or punch a
hole in your boat
holy mackerel this place is cool
look at this place
look at that snappy turtle right there
see him
look at that that is a big old snapper
whoa
you see a fish just jump out of the
water
oh i'm bumping all over cypress knees
well if we're gonna camp tonight we need
some dry land but the prop ran out of
water so uh we're gonna have to do
something about that
all right i think we found it
that's what our target is
dad looks like we're on a surfboard huh
all right we made it let's go check it
out is this thing gonna
break on us
yeah there you go
big step oh
yeah it used to be an outhouse
oh my goodness
look at this we are in the heart of this
flooded cyphers forest this is so cool
yeah i'll tell you what we go on some
pretty cool adventures but we are out in
the middle of nowhere and you're in this
forest and your voice echoes off the
trees it's it's like you're in a canyon
hello
yeah it's just sounds so cool all i can
hear is birds and fish it's just
this is pretty awesome well there's a
series of platforms like this hidden
throughout the cypress forest and me and
jake are going to explore it for three
days
we're gonna set up camp and then we're
gonna do some fishing and uh man i just
i just can't wait to find out what's
hidden in this forest
right now all right jake let's go set up
the tent well before we can do too much
exploring and fishing i've got to get
the tent set up and the boat lightened
this place is so cool
[Music]
headshots
[Applause]
all right
do you want milk yeah all right
let's check it out this stuff will last
months without refrigeration so you can
just put it in your backpack and then he
can drink it
all right we're gonna save the rest for
later that boy is a milk addict i'll
tell you what if you're gonna do these
sort of adventures with little kids make
sure you have your tent and shelter up
right away because once they get tired
of playing and want to be in their
shelter or in the tent they're not going
to give you a lot of heads up you ready
to go fishing jake
look there's some caterpillars they'll
sometimes make really good bait
platforms covered in some big
caterpillars and i see a few of them
falling in the water
there you go
you hop in there bud
all righty
we keep hitting these cypress knees
makes my heart jump every time
[Music]
see the fish jumping out of the water
isn't this a cool place
holy mackerel i can't wait to fish this
got his little caterpillar on on the
hey you hold on to that you watch that
bobber okay
man i'm seeing so many bowfin jumping
around here i would love to catch some
but both and probably aren't going to
grab caterpillars and worms they're a
little bit more aggressive predators but
if i can catch a little bluegill or
something with these worms i can use
that to catch a bowfin look at the
livescope look at all the fish swimming
down there we are just on top of tons of
fish doing much
man i'm just driving through here and
there's just buffing everywhere i've
never seen this many bowfin
boffins love to eat crawfish and there's
a lot of crawfish here
buddy we gotta fix it real quick oh look
at this look at this
man that's a healthy blue catfish
oh look at that
that's called stridulation they make
that little noise by rubbing the bone in
their spine against their shoulder blade
most of them just use the right fin but
this guy's is ambidextrous that makes
him special
oh i do have a bite
that one too look at that
oh look at that i think that's a black
bullhead right there there you go that's
a full grown one that's a nice size uh
bullhead
feisty guy
oh you got something
yes
yes the bluegill excellent look at that
that's a beautiful guy let's
put him in the water there
oh perfect look at that golden shiner
that's exactly what i need that is
perfect bait oh
there we go oh oh oh jake jake reel them
in little bit reel them in reel them in
oh yeah
oh my goodness look at the size of that
shell cracker good job that's the
biggest one so far that's oh look at
that
oh man
oh there we go nice
i think you got a fish let me see let me
see
there we go
this one is perfect for bay
we're just hitting them one after
another
let me chill
there we go
there we go
oh what is that looks like a white
catfish
look at that he's spying me
i've been spying by catfish so many
times i don't even notice anymore
[Music]
all right jacob did you bait that all by
yourself yeah good job buddy where's
your bobber reel em in
another nice bluegill look at the size
of that all right here we go
we've only been in the boat for about an
hour and a half and we've caught about
20 fish oh you got him
oh a nice bluegill do you want to go try
catching some big catfish or some bowfin
[Music]
oh there we go another pretty bluegill
well these little bluegill make great
bait for catfish and bowfin so i'm gonna
chop them up in little pieces we're
gonna see what we can catch
a little bit of that bluegill under a
bobber
just gotta check it out here and see if
those bowfin like it
but i got a sneaky suspicion that we are
going to tear up a ton of catfish
tomorrow i mean we are just seeing so
many fish
just a very greedy bowl head
oh
come here look what i got look what i
got
it's a bowfin look at that that is a
bowfin or a shoe pick or a grindel or a
mud fish depends on what part of the
country you're from depends on the name
they use
but this is a prehistoric native species
they're very predatory and they love
shallow swampy water just like this they
actually taste really good too but the
meat is really hard to preserve once you
kill the fish the meat immediately
starts to decompose and it's hard to get
it to last more than 24 hours if you eat
them right away they're delicious send
him back wink i love catching those
another lovely fish
there we go there's another bow fin
there we go
i think it's seven o'clock you want to
go home and eat dinner no you want to
stay and fish
all right
i'm getting
look at the size of that bullhead
oh
oh my goodness i just had my rod just
dangling over the side of the boat
look at there
look at that double
a beautiful beaufort
this is great
look at that
what a monster check it out i got the
fluger supreme on my catfish and carp
signature series rod and it just works
so well when i designed these fishing
rods this is exactly what i designed
them for and this is why we chose carbon
fiber because it makes little fish like
these bow fin and channel cats feel so
much fun but i can catch a 30 40 pound
catfish on this no problem so you know
they're very versatile
[Music]
oh
look at that
that fish hit it so hard about broke
this wall off my boat
well there we go channel catfish and our
fourth species of catfish today we've
got a blue a white and a black bull head
all right
well this has been fun and jacob doesn't
want to quit but we better get head and
back or we're never gonna find our
camping spot in the dark
that was awesome
and we made it safe and sound
i forgot to bring mosquito repellent
with me but uh luckily it hasn't been
too bad even though we're in the middle
of the swamp but uh i think we're gonna
go take this inside the tent
let's see
do you want beef ravioli mre
lasagna with meat sauce or cup of
noodles
[Applause]
hey dude you want to sit in bed and
watch some cartoons
no
you want to go to bed
no what do you want to do
that's your bed why don't you hop on
inside
well that's not right
there you go that's that's how you do it
you've got a little you got a little
camping pillow
me and jake are just sitting here
watching shows on our phone and you can
just hear the both and busting up in the
water around the tent they must be
coming in really shallow
you sleep well
yeah
good oh look look at mosquito
got in the tent and bit my boy
i think i caught the culprit
are you watching breakfast
how about granola granola with milk and
blueberries
what do you think buddy
does that look good
you like that
we got our breakfast mre
grape jelly
cracker syrup there's a cinnabon
hash browns and that's the patty these
mres are great for camping we got this
little heater here
and you put just a tiny bit of water in
it and it is gonna get really hot it's
getting toasty already
slide it down in this sleeve the meals
and you sandwich them on either side the
only downside is the smoke smells like a
burnt motor so i'm going to go put it
outside the tent for a little bit
do you want a cinnamon roll
there's a cinnabon cinnamon roll in my
mre
um
all right feels pretty warm
there we go we got a we got a pork
sausage there bacon onion pepper hash
brown put a little syrup on there
well they're not the best hashbrowns and
sausage you'll ever eat
but they're decent and they're warm
well we've got a lot of amazing things
planned today we're going to take the
little boat out and try to explore this
cypress forest a little bit more and see
if we can't find another one of these
old platforms to camp on
and we're going to do a lot of fishing
along the way as well so just going to
be
great day but first i gotta pack up all
this gear
six five cars oh you're poopy
what an absolutely awesome place to camp
i'm excited to see what we find next so
i think we better hop in the boat and go
find our next camping spot
it's so much quieter here i'm not seeing
as many bowfin rolling which makes a lot
of sense after last night because they
were splashing and jumping and hunting
until sunrise last night so they're
they're probably all tuckered out
look at that big snake
see him see the snake right there
[Music]
pretty sure that was a northern water
snake they look a lot like a cottonmouth
or a water moccasin but their heads are
shaped different and so to scare away
predators they flatten their head and
make their cheeks puff out to make them
look a little bit more like an adder but
if you look at the top of the head it
looks like it's squished in unlike a
cotton mouth of course i wouldn't
recommend picking up or handling either
one of them but you know whatever all
right our next spot's about six miles
downstream so uh we're gonna go make
some serious tracks hey jake you ready
to go fast
all right let's go fast
[Music]
our first obstacle is gonna be tight
we thread the needle there folks
oh i felt that on the bottom of the boat
good job buddy dunking those branches
this is gonna be tight
oh like a boss
[Music]
[Music]
well it was a little touch and go but we
made it to open water but our our
journey's not over yet we still got to
get way back into that cypress forest
i think we're getting close
all right watch your fingers
okay grab the rope
well there we go it took a couple hours
but we got here
all right shall we set up camp
all right you got camp set up i think
it's time to do a little fishing
yeah you are
look at look at how it's doing to that
rod
oh these little catfish are just amped
up
there we go nice channel catfish
whoa look at that there's another one
right there look at that
look at that
fish
not a bad blue catfish
i caught both of those in under five
minutes man there's just so many catfish
here
oh yeah
oh my goodness
[Music]
look at this
that's a big garb
hey he don't fit in the net
he is much bigger than my net
he just jumped out of the water he is
not fitting in that oh
maybe
maybe
oh
[Music]
that is a massive car look at the size
of this thing
look at the size of this
monster but look at the teeth on them
this is why you got to be super careful
now those are razor sharp teeth i've
never seen one
even half this size
here we go guy
luckily they're a really hardy fish they
can actually breathe air
and in really hot days like today
they'll come up and you'll see them
gulping air oh gosh that was pretty
awesome i love catching gar so that was
that was pretty darn cool listen this
spot obviously has a load of fish but
there's so much territory to cover here
i just wanted to see what else there is
to find
all right
oh look at this hooked this time
oh yeah oh look at the drag he's taken
oh
[Music]
guys about eight pounds nine pounds
oh well there we go we are catching some
nice fish
you're getting better jake we had a
little bit of action here but it's quiet
down we're going to go try another spot
you got a fish
you got a fish
yeah oh hold on tight don't let him take
your rod
oh and he took your hook
i'll get you a new hook well this has
been fun but it is boiling hot right now
so we're gonna go back to the tent and
grab some lunch and once it cools down a
little bit we're gonna come out here and
catch some more fish
oh
oh no jake
hey jacob what did you were you were in
the mud
give me your hand
[Laughter]
walking back to the tent and i hear this
little plop and he doesn't say a word
look over and he's just sitting there
hey jacob i think you pooped your pants
well got that all cleaned up it's
amazing what you can do with the thing
of wet wipes
all right well hey do you want some
snacks
here's some fruit snacks
[Music]
well my sunburn from spear fishing in
the florida keys is finally peely
oh
my gang came off
yeah that's not healthy
how about this you want to wait a little
bit till it's not so hot and then go
fish some more yeah
uh oh uh oh we got a little problem
jacob's got a pretty huge sliver in his
foot
look at that thing
look that is a big sliver does your toe
hurt
yeah you want me to get that sliver out
no well trust me buddy we want to get it
out
do you trust me
here libby look at that sliver
oh look at that isn't it
was that bad
yeah
ready we're gonna wrap it up in a
bandage we're gonna put a sock over it
we had to use some fishing equipment to
get that out but we got it out didn't we
yeah
no
that was one of the biggest slivers i
have ever seen it's five o'clock and
it's cooled down substantially so we're
gonna try to catch a few fish before
dinner time
here comes fat dad
you almost sound good
got a spot where two different currents
are meeting together we got this seam
here we got two different colors of
water
quite a bit of fish down there something
big right there
look at that
i was kind of bouncing the bait up and
down trying to feel the bottom and i got
hit that did not take any time at all
little blue catfish
good cast bud
[Music]
second catfish in five minutes
all right jake should we go try another
spot
all right we're here fishing another
spot and i've got a sneaky suspicion
that all of the spots on this river are
pretty darn good
oh it's another huge gar if i had to
caught this gar this morning this would
have been the biggest gar i'd ever seen
gar here are massive
geez
[Music]
oh
holy crap that was a catfish just jumped
out of the water all the years i've been
fishing for catfish i've never had one
jump out of the water like a bath before
oh
there we go
this rod just got hit oh beautiful
catfish get them out of there
oh
another healthy catfish just slamming
them
all of our rods out of the water
they get wrapped up in your line
he shredded the line anyways
that is a beautiful beautiful fish
gar smell different than any other fish
i think they smell a little bit like
diesel fuel
well we've been in the boat for only a
little over an hour and we've had some
pretty awesome fishing but jake's hungry
and wants to go back to the tent so
we're gonna do just that
good job you are so helpful
ravioli
beef brisket lasagna
or curry or cup of noodle
cup of noodle all right
[Music]
all right we got the beef brisket mre my
brisket santa fe beans and rice ooh
fruit punch
pea spread with bacon
and a cracker
oh we also got pop tarts
you like that
yeah there's the beef brisket and gravy
the santa fe beans and rice looks like
something i took out of jacob's diaper
earlier today do you like the mres yeah
they're great
i mean it's obviously not as good as
fresh stuff but it's not bad
do you like your cup of noodle yeah
old jacob has caught the fishing bug
badly we get done with dinner and i look
up and he's sneaking out of the tent
he's gone down to the boat got his
fishing rod and is trying to fish off
the dock little guy's baiting his own
rod and casting by himself i'm pretty
proud of him it's not bad for a
three-year-old come on buddy it's
bedtime we got to get going to bed
are you upset that we're not fishing
her power is with the respect they
deserve oh he had a great day and
jacob's already asleep
i'm gonna sit here and just watch a
movie on my phone and go to bed and
i'll see you guys in the morning
yeah i've camped in some beautiful
places before
something about these cypher swamps is
just
awesome
do you sleep well yeah
well now that we got breakfast out of
the way we got to break camp and get the
boat loaded quick because we have a long
way back to the boat ramp and we need to
go a different route than with the way
we came also jacob wants to do a little
fishing and i want to get this on the
water before it gets too hot
this was another incredible camping spot
what a great time
you ready jake
[Music]
look at this that's a big
[Music]
[Music]
we're gonna stop and do a little fishing
here see what we can do watch fingers
we ran the boat for almost an hour we
haven't seen a single person this is
amazing look at all the marks down here
there's a lot of fish moving around
they're big healthy blue catfish
man this river's just full of these
look at that boy he has just gotten so
good at fishing this is i'm so proud of
him look at that screamer
it's a nice blue catfish
whew
we still have a long ways to go on our
journey so i think we better reel up and
uh keep trucking
look at that jake it's a shipwreck
yeah that looks expensive
do you want to do that again yeah
well i hope you guys enjoyed watching
that video because me and jacob sure
enjoyed filming it if you guys want to
see more camping and adventures check
out our camping and adventure playlist
i'll put links in the video description
below and don't forget to click
subscribe we put out new videos every
saturday morning
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every saturday morning and hit
that bell button you'll get
notifications thanks for watching